У нас тут поблизу і не було його, того коронавірусу.
А я думала, що до мене то не дійде, думала, та я стара,
я вже так обійдуся. Як це ті, як їх?.. Тести беруть, я думаю,
та я вже і так витримаю, а воно не получилося…
Антоніні Самчишиній - 88 років. Вона лежить в коридорі
Любарської районної лікарні, сюди її поклали 10 днів тому.
Зять привіз її просто здати аналіз. Тоді не вистачило місця
в палатах - тож поклали просто у коридорі.
А потім лікарі розширили відділення ще на кілька палат.
У них тепер лежить і її зять. Переїхати в палату до всіх
пані Антоніна відмовилася - каже, тут на коридорі
людей менше і повітря чистіше.
Я так собі тут сяду, подивилася і думаю: Боже, весь народ слабий!
Всі люди вмирають, всі слабнуть. Чого він такий став?
Як був колись грип, прийшов, полікували та й нічого.
А це - всі люди слабі... Страшне...
Любарську лікарню за 100 кілометрів від Житомира
переобладнали на "ковідну" ще на початку пандемії.
На відміну від багатьох районних лікарень тут уже тоді була
окрема будівля - інфекційне відділення
та одна лікарка-інфекціоністка у штаті. Але цього дуже швидко
стало замало: під лікування хворих з "ковідом" довелося
віддати весь другий поверх лікарні. Раніше там була терапія.
Одна людина не може обслужити там 40 людей,
бо то в комбінезонах, респіраторах, проставити всі маніпуляції.
Це просто нереально. Тобто ми стараємося, щоб бригада
працювала десь 20 чоловік, ну 30 максимум.
Теоретично покласти ми їх можемо, ми маємо де,
але хто їх буде обслуговувати? Не буде ким…
Пустим ліжко тут буває недовго: санітарки тільки
встигають переобрати, а вже нові пацієнти чекають
на госпіталізацію.
Ось ця жінка тільки приїхала. Ще я її не подивилася, тобто вона ковідна.
Лариса Коколюк до пандемії була єдиною інфекціоністкою
на весь Любар. А зараз ще з десяток її колег-медиків
змінили свої профілі на інфекційну патологію.
Але навіть вона зі своїм досвідом досі не може звикнути
до жорсткості коронавірусу.
У нас в інфекційній патології немає такої високої смертності.
Були патології, але ми вміли їх лікувати.
Розумієте, це для мене трагедія. Що вводиш всі ліки по протоколу,
а людина при повній свідомості помирає. Розумієте?..
Раніше такого не було. У нас в інфекції практично ніхто не помирав.
На Житомирщині від початку пандемії вже дві з половиною тисячі
людей померли від "ковіду". В області на початок листопада
хворіє 19 тисяч. До лікарень госпіталізують лише тих,
хто не може дихати без кисню.
Валерій Галицький ще рік тому лікував вухо-горло-ніс
у любарців, а тепер бореться за кожен їхній подих.
Розповідає, що вже був такий період літом, коли хворих
можна було порахувати на пальцях. Але любарці не надто активно
вакцинувалися, тож тепер знову щодня госпіталізують
з десяток нових інфікованих.
Ми не вакцинуємо, але взагалі з вакцинальної компанії
є не так вже й багато протипоказань. Більшість людей,
особливо старшого віку, їм необхідно вакцинуватися.
Але є спеціальна антивакцинальна кампанія, яка, звичайно,
породжена недостатністю знань.
Від хати під лісом у селі Великі Деревичі, де живе пані Антоніна,
до районного центру Любара, де вона найближче могла
отримати вакцину, -  17 кілометрів маршруткою.
Але вірус сюди доїхав швидше, аніж вакцина.
Ще мені ніхто не казав. Я стара. Думаю, я ще побуду і так.
Знаєте, а я пенсію получала, то думаю, я буду на смерть
складати вже, бо я стара.
Валерій Галицький, лікар пані Антоніни каже,
що пік захворюваності для неї вже минув і що навіть
попри хворе серце їй вже майже вдалося перемогти вірус.
Що будете робити як додому приїдете?
Буду сидіти в хаті! Є в мене дрова,
є в мене газ. Я можу палити і сидіти.